IS COMING FROM THE MEDIA WHO
HATES TO COVER IT.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION
FROM ORLANDO IS ROGER STONE, A
POLITICAL CONSULTANT AND FORMER
I COMPILED THAT MONTAGE FOR YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU LOVE TO BE
REMINDED OF ALL THE WIT AND
WISDOM AND PROGNOSTICATION
SKILLS OF THE COMMENTARIAT THAT
FORTH.
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT YOU
BELIEVE IS REALLY GOING ON WITH
SOMEONE LIKE JOE SCARBOROUGH WHO
USED TO BE A REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
MEN.
>> THE FIRST THING YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT ALL OF THIS
MEANS THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION HAS
FAILED.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA
PRODUCING NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
OF REAL RUSSIAN COLLUSION TO
ASSIST IN THE ELECTION OF
DONALD TRUMP HAVE NOW SWITCHED
TO PLAN B.
PLAN B ISN'T DONALD TRUMP IS
NUTS.
HE HAS HIS EX HIS EX AND TO
SENTRIES, THEODORE ROOSEVELT,
ANDREW JACKSON.
IN A CASE OF A GUY LIKE JOE
SCARBOROUGH, THIS IS BITTER
JEALOUSY.
THE ENTIRE TIME HE WAS IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, HE
TOLD HIS AIDES HE WOULD SOMEDAY
BE PRESIDENT.
ONE DONALD TRUMP WAS NOMINATED,
JOE SCARBOROUGH THOUGHT HE
SHOULD BE THE NOMINEE.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP CHOSE
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE JOE
SCARBOROUGH THOUGHT HE SHOULD BE
WE NOW KNOW IT WAS MIKA WHO
RECOMMENDED POWELL FOR THE
NATIONAL SECURITY DIRECTOR IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY HAVE
TURNED ON HIM OUT OF BITTERNESS.
THIS IS THE ESTABLISHMENTS NEXT
NARRATIVE.
IT IS A PRECURSOR FOR A 25TH
AMENDMENT ARGUMENTS.
>> Laura: I SAID FROM DAY ONE,
THEY KEPT PREDICTING HIS
NARRATIVE THAT BOLSTERS THEIR
SAID ON "THE TODAY SHOW" THIS
MORNING WITH SAVANNAH GUTHRIE,
THIS IS MICHAEL WOLFF WHO WROTE
THIS LURID BOOK, LET'S WATCH.
>> IT WAS EVERY 25 OR
NOW IT'S THE SAME THREE STORIES
EVERY 10 MINUTES.
I WILL QUOTE STEVE BANNON.
HE'S LOST THAT.
>> ACCORDING TO THIS REPORT HE
SAYS HE'S LOST THAT.
I'VE BEEN AROUND THE PRESIDENT,
I REPEAT THINGS, I GIVE SPEECHES
I SAY THE SAME ANECDOTES.
TWO PEOPLE HAVE A STOPWATCH IN
THERE?
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT GIVEN
MR. WOLF'S LONG HISTORY OF A
FABRICATOR AND A FICTIONAL
WRITER.
I THINK THE FACTS ARE IN.
YOU MIGHT CHALK THIS UP TO
ANIMUS IF IT HAD HAPPENED AFTER
WHITE HOUSE PAYROLL AND HE OWED
HIS LOYALTY TO DONALD TRUMP.
THE IDEA THAT THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T WANT TO WIN, DIDN'T
EXPECT TO WIN?